he may be the First Avenger but he isn't
the chosen one and now we might know why
as a hilarious new fan theory may
explain just why Captain America was
unable to lift Thor's mystical hammer
Mjolnir in Avengers age of Ultron as
most Marvel fans know the hammer had an
enchantment on it that only allowed it
to be lifted by those deemed worthy
whosoever be he worthy shall haveth up
whatever man it's a trick please be my
guest
in the comics of course Captain America
has lifted Thor's hammer several times
first and most famously in the pages of
Thor number 390 in the movies however
the only people who have been able to
lift Mjolnir are the vision and of
course Thor himself though Steve Rogers
was able to at least budge the hammer
something even war machine and iron man
were unable to do despite their
incredible strength so why is the movie
version of Steve Rogers unable to lift
the hammer
reddit user paramecia antic has an
insane and pretty funny theory that
suggests that steve's decision to ride a
motorcycle without a helmet at the end
of Avengers is proof of his total
disdain for laws and authority which
other editors quickly seized upon as the
reason he's unworthy to have to mule
near the helmet
Oh Oh I've got a helmet of course we
have our own theory sure Captain America
is worthy of lifting a hammer but you
know who isn't the Human Torch and those
aren't the only comic book characters
Chris Evans has played he's also
appeared in adaptations of Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles
snowpiercer Scott Pilgrim vs. the world
and the losers it was a secret
government experiment he did stuff to me
spooky stuff that's why the hammer only
budged when he tried to lift it because
only part of him was worthy even worried
about myself
I know what people taste like that's
gross
then again everyone has their own theory
even the people who make the movies back
in 2015 during San Diego comic-con a fan
asked age of ultron writer director Joss
Whedon why Steve Rogers isn't considered
worthy and why he couldn't properly lift
mule NIR we didn't suggested that maybe
he is worthy but just didn't want to
lift it saying are we sure did he fail
or did he stop in 2016 sibling
filmmakers Joe and Anthony Russo
mentioned to Huffington Post that
Captain America wielding Mjolnir might
be a question for future storytellers
and that it might be a little too
specific for us to answer back then the
Russos were chatting about their film
Captain America Civil War but in the
year since the pair went on to direct
Avengers infinity war and they're also
behind the lens for Avengers 4 so those
future storytellers they referenced back
then may actually be the Russo brothers
themselves now confusing right but that
little time paradox may actually be in
keeping with rumored plans to have cap
actually lift Mjolnir in Avengers for
sure it's true that Thor's original
hammer was destroyed and thor ragnarok
by his evil sister hella requiring him
to make an all-new weapon the god killer
Stormbreaker in Avengers infinity war
but according to a since deleted reddit
post purporting to have secret
information about the plot of Avengers 4
the team will travel back in time to
fight Thanos and after a Mjolnir
wielding Thor is struck down in battle
by Thanos Captain America will lift the
hammer and gain the power of the Thunder
God for a final showdown of epic
proportions no one can say for certain
whether that will definitely happen but
we wouldn't be surprised if Avengers 4
really will include some element of time
travel bring Mjolnir back into Thor's
life and give Captain America a shiny
hammer to go with this signature shield
after that jaw-dropping twist at the end
of infinity war we're expecting the
unexpected when it comes to the next
Avengers movie we just hope that it's
all worth the wait
[Music]